accepted division
this is a war you can't win keeler's
legacy will live on
i'd be dead if it wasn't for you i won't
let you down
not again
[Music]
having technically already died once one
of kena's lieutenants from the division
one
is back and more loyal to kina's cause
than ever
hornet kena's most trusted agent is
leading a sell of rogues to fulfill his
legacy
but who are they and what are they
[Music]
planning
[Music]
in the early days carter leroux code
named hornet
had his entire career path planned out
for him by his parents
studying economics he was eventually
interning for the family firm
but after a short stint he felt
unsatisfied with this direction
and chose to sign up with the armed
forces
hornet joined the army and was stationed
in djibouti africa
during this time he met future rogue
agent aaron kina
and they quickly struck up a friendship
becoming close brothers in arms
after he returned home family tensions
left hornet feeling alienated and alone
he was lost and unsure of what to do
with his life next
after everything he had seen he just
couldn't return to a desk job
however he managed to keep in touch with
kina who knew where he was coming from
and suggested he do something positive
with his life and sign up to the
division
kena put hornet in touch with division
recruiter elijah lee
who quickly signed him up due to his
capabilities and experience
what do you think about kaduna
recommended him said they grew up
together
grew up together his file says he grew
up in michigan
that's not exactly jersey looks like
they served together in djibouti
figures stick a bunch of guys in a room
throw in some guns and an existential
threat
and the next thing you know they're all
reborn and calling each other brother
it says he volunteered for service
that's exactly what scares me
he's a thrill seeker big game hunter
former futures trader
sound familiar what kind of person takes
frequent trips to zimbabwe to slaughter
two ton animals after returning from a
war zone
a person who isn't afraid of a challenge
or a person with a taste for killing
he follows the law plays by the rules
wants to say we can't use that we could
do with a few more people like him to
balance the books a little
if we're rubber stamping this guy you're
responsible for him if he starts
hunting again however when kena turned
rogue
hornet was the first agent to answer his
call with their history he would
continue to follow kena's every move
after the second wave was activated
division agents were called upon to
retrieve the russian virologist
vitali trinenko in the russian embassy
kina called upon hornet to secure
trenenko before the division got to him
finding him locked up in a safe room
within the embassy hornet used a
breaching charge to blow open a wall
while the division were on the other
side of the safe room trying to talk the
way in
the division pursued but hornet managed
to extract the russian scientist
in a helicopter before they caught up to
him
in an attempt to stall the agents
hornets stayed behind
and engaged them head-on the division
managed to overwhelm
and take him down leaving him for dead
the division moved on to return the
information they had found on site
to the base of operations having been
fed information from a man on the inside
keenan made his way to the russian
consulate outside
he found hornet severely injured and
dying
kina brought him to lori baker a rogue
agent and former army surgeon
who managed to bring him back from the
brink of death i can't believe you came
for me you don't leave a brother in the
field
especially not on foreign soil i lost
jerninkal's research
it's okay i failed you forget the
consulate
you survived you didn't fail me
this is just a setback i'd be dead if it
wasn't for you
your heart stopped for a couple of
seconds so you were technically dead
but termites good she brought you back
if you boys are done making out i'd
really like to move
this location's not secure can you walk
i'll get it together
you're stronger than anyone could ever
know and i know
you will do great things i won't let you
down
not again this action only further
enhanced
on its loyalty to kina becoming his
closest ally in the days to come
he vowed to do everything in his power
to help keen her on his mission
working behind the scenes kinder
eventually resurfaced
with a new variation of the virus that
started it all
with some of his rogue agents he
attacked city hall in lower manhattan
while kena had the division's attention
he tasked hornet with getting to
washington dc
and recruiting an army to help with the
cause
to help him get the job done kena
supplied him with a number of eclipse
virus samples
that he could use to persuade any likely
candidates
hornets set up for dc along with four
other rogue agents
consisting of termite titan luna and
huntsman
lori baker code named termite was
trained as an army surgeon
and took part in a number of military
conflicts overseas
she was eventually dismissed from the
military after failing to follow orders
told to retreat during an attack on a
hostile base in southern afghanistan
she instead opted to stay tending to a
group of wounded soldiers
but this impressed division recruiters
showing independence
and the ability to make difficult
decisions in high stress situations
she was recruited and trained as a first
wave division agent
once activated termat was tasked with
securing a quarantine centre that was
set up by the government
in new york city but after witnessing
the effect of the green poison
she began to lose confidence in the
division's goal believing that the only
way to control this breed
was to eliminate the sick and dying
what's her condition high fever and
abdominal pains move her to quarantine
her test results came back negative
she's clean
it's not green poison we can't take any
chances the medical wing is full we have
people sleeping in hallways and
bathrooms it's like
an incubation chamber she can't stay
here i am not gambling with her life
if we put her in quarantine with her
immune system compromise she won't make
it a week
and send her on her way you can't keep
admitting people off the streets like
this
i don't take my orders from the division
she's staying
the time to start listening was
yesterday if you keep insisting on
making the wrong choices i'll have to
make the right ones for you
they're weak they won't survive we can't
just leave them
i'm not suggesting we leave them what
are you suggesting
do you really need me to say it say it
it's over
the more we fight it the stronger it
gets there's only one option left
you sound just like those people out
there burning this city to ash
we've seen this all before viruses
appear and spread but ultimately
they are defeated not this time
eventually the cleaners arrived to
cleanse the hospital
seeing this as an opportunity termite
disavowed the division
instead of holding off the attack she
killed a number of division agents and
jtf
allowing the cleaners to break through
the defense in turn killing all patients
and staff on site i'm
impressed i don't have time for your
[ __ ] yeah it takes a particularly
strong
or broken person to facilitate mass
euthanasia
you don't strike me as broken you
understand
what we're up against listen if you're
trying to get me to repopulate the earth
with you you're barking up the wrong
tree oh god no
children are for people with free time
and our time is limited
if we don't do something about it you
have to think about what kind of legacy
you want to leave
you got something in mind no i got a
plan
and i just need to know if you're
committed give me the elevator pitch and
i'll tell you
we're going to eradicate the weak
i'm in kenya saw this as an opportunity
to recruit another agent to the cause
turmoil would later be responsible for
nursing hornet back to health
before eventually heading off to
washington dc on the recruitment mission
tegan silva codenamed luna comes from
the security industry
where she's extensive experience she was
working for the state department in
washington dc
when she was activated her role was
involved with closely monitoring
internal operations but when president
ellis ordered the jtf's withdrawal from
the dark zone in new york
she began to lose faith in the
government's ability to control the
situation
you hear about new york there is a
massive outbreak in quarantine
division agents have been activated to
assist the jtf in regaining control of
the city
yeah i heard the jtf pulled out
[ __ ] decided they lost enough people
built a wall
locked it down walled off the sick
hostiles any agent foolish enough to
stay behind
they can't do that they can't just leave
agents to die
apparently they can we have to do
something
we have to stop them who gave the order
ellis
it's too late gave the order an hour ago
rumor is jtf moved out and the cleaners
moved in
they're currently sterilizing the area
some time later after keena went rogue
and started recruiting
elani calso brought luna some encrypted
echoes to reconstruct
these have been sent over by the
division in new york
hey tegan you busy nope i've got time i
need you to work on some echoes for me
you got the base data i can make you an
echo no no
i don't need you to make me an echo i
need you to fix them okay
you have the files got a data transfer
from an agent in new york
lee lao low something like that she's
been collecting encrypted echoes
i was hoping that maybe one of our techs
could find anything to help her
identify or locate these rogues i'll do
what i can tegan you're the best
oh you occur although luna was tasked
with tracking the rogue agents down
she found herself listening to a man who
shared her views
becoming a believer in kina's vision for
the future she managed to create a
connection to the rogue network
frequency that he was using
[Music]
vanguard luna how did you get on this
line
uh your encryption isn't bad but i
cracked it in maybe 20 minutes
you're lucky alani brought me your
echoes to crack i've been
listening i want to help how do i know i
can trust you
well you'll have to take my word for it
for now that's all i've got
words mean nothing without actions what
can you offer you've seen what i can do
the division still thinks i'm one of
them so you want to be my
man on the inside i do sir
i think it's criminal what they did to
you no one can realistically think that
the way out of this crisis is to save
what remains
i'm glad you understand what we're
trying to do here there's only one way
to end tyranny
anarchy you're a smart cookie
luna had become keen as agent on the
inside of the division and was able to
feed him intel
allowing him to continue to be several
steps ahead of them
it was luna that informed keener of the
division's operation to secure vitaliy
dranenko
at the russian consulate this gave kena
the opportunity to react
and warn hornet of their approach this
warning however
would ever finally being flagged as a
rogue agent
she would be reassigned to a position of
surveillance for kina's operation
elijah lee code named huntsman worked in
the bomb disposal unit in afghanistan
over time he earned a silver star for
bravery
however after tripping an explosive
device one day he was given an honorable
discharge
and spent a year undergoing physical
therapy for his injuries
later on he was hired by the division as
a recruiter
in fact he was the one responsible for
hiring both kina and hornet
[Music]
when the situation arose and the first
wave of agents were activated
huntsman used the opportunity to join
them out in the field as an agent
but over time like many before him he
lost faith in the division's ability to
get on top of the situation
and with the deployment of the last man
battalion he saw them as the ones
who would be able to get on top of the
anarchy that was starting to unfold
i just want you to understand one thing
charles
i'm not doing this because i think the
division was a mistake i'm doing this
because the division is failing
right now the last man battalion has the
best chance to take control of this [ __ ]
show besides i always look good in
winter camo
eventually the division took down the
last man battalion leader charles bliss
and after his death huntsman was left
not knowing what to do
lost of course thanks to luna's intel
keenan knew all about his situation and
offered him a job
i was sorry to hear about bliss charles
was a good man
a good man don't make it very far in
this world what do you want keener to
give you a job
i've got a job without bliss your
buddies won't stick around
they'll join the next pmc to come along
and promise them a hot meal
you know i'm not like that i do
you're committed you're loyal once you
make a decision you stick with until you
decide to abandon it
only two things you've ever quit of the
division and that copper spaniel
kept pissing on your carpet [ __ ] that
dog and the ex-wife he rode in on
that's her problem now this wasn't a
problem
karen died last week i guess there's a
silver lining
where you getting your intel i got
someone in dc
luna's got her ear to the ground and an
eye in the sky
say hi hey huntsman who the [ __ ] is
huntsman
you are if you're ready
jason barnes codenamed titan spent 10
years as a firefighter
before gaining a diploma in wildland
fire science and training as a smoke
jumper after years of witnessing the
destruction of nature
he became an outspoken environmentalist
he was noticed by the division after he
survived for six days stuck in a
wildland fire that took the lives of the
rest of his unit
due to quickly spreading fires in city
parks titan was recruited
and then quickly activated during the
second wave he didn't actually receive
any formal division training we're
activating the second wave we need you
in new york
is it as bad as they say it is it's
worse and it's not just the green poison
that's spreading
we've got paranoid residents burning
everything in sight it's raining ash and
the fire department's overwhelmed
there's no way inside unless you go in
from the top
think you can handle it i can handle it
what do you need from me
you'll drop down over central park we
need you to coordinate the trench build
along the perimeter
what do you need from us a pretty orange
watch you're easy to please
just send a helo and brief briefly on
the way thank you
and welcome to the division agent
after being treated for severe smoke
inhalation he was taken to a sarah
hospital
where he was surrounded by victims of
the green poison
he saw firsthand the destruction caused
by the virus
although titan was injured he refused to
stay in the hospital
even with a nurse trying to stop him
titan got as far away from there as
possible
i know you're only doing what you think
is right
and in some way i admire that
truth is i don't understand what you're
fighting for
and i don't think you do either you call
this
a crisis you think that death
is a tragedy but the real tragedy
is how our innate desire for survival
overshadows our appreciation for life
this is an opportunity how much
devastation
will it take to realize that perhaps we
are the poison maybe it's time to accept
our punishment
and let nature decide what's best for
the world
this experience led him to question
everything that they were doing
as a true eco-terrorist he began
wondering if this whole thing was
nature's way
of trying to survive jason barnes
the agent with no official division
training
congratulations on the promotion seems
like you're smarter than the rest of us
you didn't call to give me compliments
keener i
liked your manifesto thought i'd share
my enthusiasm
you've got it all wrong sooner or later
we're all gonna die
i guess the real question is what do you
want to leave behind
that's the point i don't want to leave
anything behind
i'm not even a legacy green poison will
run its course
and then the same people who trashed
this planet will try to rebuild it and
end up destroying it for good
but with a little intervention you could
change
that future even though the goals were
different
the methods of getting there were the
same titan agreed to join keener in his
rogues
and stop humanity from continuing down
the same path they were headed before
the outbreak
once in dc hornet set forth with
recruiting
he saw the outcasts as good place to
start since they were currently
leaderless
and in need of a purpose but they aren't
exactly friendly to strangers
however he had a different way of
getting their attention
what the hell happened here you think it
was the true sons
it's not like them this was chemical
maybe it was green poison impossible
people don't just drop dead like that
stay away from that smoke
it's called eclipse don't [ __ ] move
careful his watch is red
relax i keep my eyes open the jtf had
been causing you trouble
thought i'd ease that burden for you
besides
i needed to get your attention somehow
your people aren't too friendly to
strangers
we should kill them i wouldn't advise
that fear green poison is the only real
weapon you have and that won't last much
longer with antivirals starting to
circulate
you've seen what the eclipse virus is
capable of and i've got plenty to go
around
it was around this time that the
division had caught up to kinah and
after chasing clues around southern
manhattan
they eventually faced off of them on
liberty island
where he was finally brought down and
eliminated
this lead to in-house fighting between
huntsman and hornet
with huntsman eager to take over where
kina liftoff
and hornet kena's closest ally having
vowed to keep things on track
hornet who died and put you in charge
[ __ ] you huntsman
a real leader knows how to work through
his grief without lashing out at others
sure you trying to make this power play
now
that's just perfect do you think you're
half as smart as he was
oh i don't think i know and face it kid
you're not ready to leave this up why
don't you let the adults handle this one
keener left me
in charge he trusted me with the eclipse
recipe
you're not a leader you're just running
around
stinging my ass and you're just a creepy
ass spider hiding in the corner
too small and chicken [ __ ] to do
anything regardless of how poisonous
your bite may be
you've been working on that for a while
now kid haven't you fallen
or get the [ __ ] out each one of hornet's
team of rogue agents
split up to cover more ground in dc
termites set off attacking multiple
sites including bank headquarters
the federal emergency bunker manning
national zoo
and camp white oak while titan focused
on the western side of dc
including the pentagon and darpa labs
huntsman made moves in southeastern dc
capturing multiple sites of value
in judiciary square federal triangle
south west
and east mall while luna continued to
run surveillance from safe safehouse in
new york
one by one the division was able to
locate the rogue agents in dc
including luna's whereabouts in lower
manhattan although they put up a strong
fight
the division agents were quickly able to
take them down
while all of this was happening hornet
was at tidal basin
with his new army of outcasts as
burkina's instructions
he'd been busy producing stockpiles of
the eclipse virus and was getting ready
to move out
the loss of his team of rogues meant
that the division was quickly able to
locate him
the division assaulted the compound only
slowing down to avoid the pockets of
eclipse virus
that horner had released across the site
in an attempt to block
and kill the agents after fighting
through waves of outcast forces
the division managed to destroy the
virus supplies
while frantically loading the remaining
supplies onto the hovercraft
hornet and his outcasts were attempting
to escape before the division were able
to reach them
but the agents caught up to him quickly
dealing to the outcasts
and destroying disciples on board hornet
launched an attack on the division
however they proved too much and were
able to bring him down and eliminate him
this time for good
kinah recruited many rogue agents a
number we're still yet to see
in each case we see how he has
manipulated threatened or bribed them
into joining his cause
however when it came to hornet there
seemed to be a legitimate bond there
with mutual respect from both sides
keena generally kept his rogues in a
need-to-know basis situation
they were kept in the dark but with
hornet
he seemed to be able to confide in him
and keep him completely up to speed on
what he was planning to do
this is certainly a side of kinder that
we haven't seen up until now
it'll be interesting to see if there
were any more agents that were able to
tap into his more vulnerable side
but i guess we'll have to wait until the
next season's come out anyway that's all
from me
if you have any questions just let me
know in the comments otherwise i'll
catch you in the next one
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
cheers
[Music]